να συνεκριμένω προφίλ ατόμου ήμουν αυτό τον συγκεκεριμένον προφίλ μου έδωσαν κάποια προσφορά την οποία
δεν μπορούσαν από όχι ηλαδή ήταν τόσον καλών το ικονομικό πακέτων πουτε κάντω σκεφτικά ούτε
καν ήξερα που έμπερνα αλλά είπαν ναι και για τα επόυμενα τέσσερα χρόνια δούλεψα στην
ίσως τη μεγαλύτερη ενεπετυτική τραπεζα του κόσμου την κόλμα σα δουλεψα στο λοδίνο δούλεψα νέα
οιόρκη και ταν φοβερές εμπιρίες διαμένητα σχολείν και για την περαιτέρω επαγγελματική μου πορία τα
τέσερα χρόνια στην τράβεζα ο άντρας νεο κλέους γνώριζε για της ήταν βριβρεθεί στο δημόνι
δηλαδή γνώριζε τη σημαίνει αυτόν το καράβι για κάποιο σιο νέόταν ήλθα κύπρο τα πρώτα
ευτά χρόνια που δούλεψαν στην έριξον ο πελάτης ομοναδικός μας πελάτης ο λόγος που υπήρχε
ντο γραφείω τις έριξων στην κύπρο ήταν ησύδα καμουν υπεύθυνος γι αυτό των πελάτη ο
πότε απότην πρώτη μέρα πρώτην του μάρκτη του δύο λές τέερα μέχρη και το δύο
χιλιάδες έντεκα των ιούλιον ήμο συνεχώς σε επαφή με τη σύρ συνεχώς κάθε μέρα δηλαδή
μπορά σου πω τρεις ημέρε της ευδόματας ήπου στα γραφία τη σύρ ο πότε αντιλαμβάνε
σε ότι είχα πάρα παρα πολύ καλή γνώση τούτη ισίδα από τα ετά χρόνια που
είμουν στν έρι ακολούθος μετά που πήγαν στην έπτιε πάλι είχα να κάμωμε τη σίδα
αλλά πλέως σαν ανταγωνιστείς δηλαδή μελαιτούσα τησίδα όλα τα πράγματα που έκανε και τα σωστά
καιτα λάθει για να δώ πως θα τα αντιμετωποίς πτε και τα πέντε χρόνια στην
πτι ήταν λες και με προετί μαζαν για των επόμενο μουρολο δηλαδή είχαμια συτία δόδεκα
χρόνο στην οποία προετιμαζόμουν για το τημόνι διανα είνι